- Hello, welcome to the
Library of Congress.
The Library of Congress is the
largest library in the world.
- [Narrator] Located in Washington, D.C.,
this collection of over 160 million items
is a vast archive of the
history of the United States.
There are over 70 special collections
that include rare manuscripts,
maps, sheet music,
and much more.
- Hello, I'm Helena Zinkham,
Director for Collections
and also Chief of the
Princeton Photographs Division.
This collection of pictures
numbers more than 15 million.
Among the rarest pictures
in our collection,
we have the migrant mother,
the iconic woman representing
the entire Great Depression.
The pictures bring people together.
They invite you in to look
around and explore worlds
that you might never be
able to see in person.
- Hello, I am Paulette Hasier.
I am the chief of the
Geography and Map Division.
We have 5.5 million maps,
80,000 atlases, 500 globes.
We have Lewis and Clark's
maps, George Washington's maps.
We have the first map that
shows the name America on it.
We're part of the bigger, broader world.
And as we look at some of
these cartographic evidence
of the changes over time,
it's a realization that we, as a nation,
have changed over time.
- Hi, I'm Sue Vita, the
chief of the Music Division.
There are about 24 million
items in the music collection.
We have Stradivari instruments.
We have the original Rhapsody in Blue.
The original edition of
the Star Spangled Banner.
Music tells us more about who we are
and tells us about our
past and our future.
- Hi, my name is Michael North,
and I'm head of Reference
and Reader Services
in the Rare Book and
Special Collections Division
at the Library of Congress.
This collection holds over 800,000 items.
We have everything from
medieval manuscripts,
early printed books, the
libraries of Thomas Jefferson.
One of our most famous books
is the Gutenberg Bible.
It's important to have
a record of the past
so that we know how we came
to be where we are today,
both in terms of ideas
and in terms of history,
politics, art, everything.
- Hi, I'm Malea Walker.
I'm a reference librarian
in the Serial and Government
Publications Division.
This collection is massive.
We have 800,000 reels of microfilm.
We have about 7.2 million
loose issues of newspapers
and approximately 42,000 volumes
of bound newspaper pages.
We also have about 140,000
issues of comic books.
One of the great things
about reading newspapers
is that you get a sense of what
it's like to be an American.
You are reading how people
lived the history itself.
- Collections are our way of
adding memory and remembrances.
All of the collections
give meaning and context
to the human experience
and the history of culture.